[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où jaillit
car bien sûr
aujourd'hui c'est camille verdez vous
êtes le fer une petite déclaration c'est
possible j'aimerais voilà allez-y aussi
pour soi même rejoindre là oui bien sûr
voilà cyril ma petite chicha j't'aime
comme on aime celui qu'on a cherché
éternellement jusqu à le trouver à
ouarzazate
si lille jeu tu es mon coeur tu es mon
âme tu es mon millésime ma plus belle
année cyril c'est pour ça que j'aimerais
te demande est là devant les
téléspectateurs avec tout mon amour avec
toute ma passion avec tous vivent des
vies dans extraordinaire et dans le ça
veut rien dire j'ai pas essayé
est-ce que cyril mon petit couscous
royal
tu aimerais qu'on reprenne tous les deux
stoppez la torah d'un but for te plaît
pas trop radin laisse pas avoir par le
direct je veux bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
après une heure dans ce cas là gilbert
l'empiré watt d'or 40 piges
non mais sans déconner un patient
souffre et tout va bien